Michael Rapaport back here how are you
Michael I'm good rich how you doing I'm
good
so I'll give you the floor what do you
think I know you sent out a video after
you heard cams comments yesterday do you
think it was a fireable offense for you
no I I just heard I just found out that
he got fired from listening to you I
think it's a joke I think it's
completely ridiculous I think it's
pathetic
that he got fired for some nonsense
listen what he said you girl yeah okay
that's a silly comment it's stupid
it could be deemed as offensive put it
this way rich let's say I showed up at a
dressmaking uh press conference and I've
been studying and learning about dresses
and I said you know the head dress maker
hey um can you tell me the thread count
and the kind of fabric and cotton you
used in that dress the lady might go huh
that's funny you you're asking that cuz
cuz it's unusual right no one would pay
attention I wouldn't get offended about
it you know for them to make this big of
a deal over something that like that is
ridiculous we're living in a politically
correct
you know handcuffed society I've heard
some some other sports people this
morning over in the ER he was television
talking he's of Cam Newton kidnapped her
dog tortured it and then and then so
feel killed it and ask for ransom money
you're making his big deal over this
thing first of all we got a president
that's totally off his rocker
but what cam specifically said and the
fact that camp does so much for the
human community he does so much with
kids he and it doesn't matter if he does
or he does it doesn't matter if it was
you know someone who just doesn't say it
doesn't matter if I said that are pure
city the fact that people are in such an
uproar over a little side comments like
oh yeah that was a silly comment we
don't care like he needs to make a
public apology to who and why did you
need to make a public apology apology to
that reporter he should apologize the
millions and millions and millions of
women in the world also give me a
frickin break yeah I wish I could
kurz rich I think it's totally
ridiculous it's totally over the top
it's I'm offended that people are this
offended by it I think it's crazy I
think it's insane that in 2017 you know
I don't want equal rights get equal
right then it doesn't like it's like
we're gonna still be like offended by
that kind of a like a little sort of off
comment well Michael let me just give
you let me give you a little bit of
pushback then it is it was it was
offensive to just I'm speaking again in
the world of sports journalism it was a
legitimate question it was a it did it
elicits a good answer once he got
through his snide comment again I do not
believe it rises to the offense of him
having to lose a job woman or to a guy
he's rude every single freaking week of
his career to every single reporter no
matter what they ask or who asked it
someone says the thing we accept because
it's Bill Belichick and he's the
football guy Popovich who I love you
know does the same thing other other
coaches do it also and this this is a
joke to me if it chokes me and there's a
woman spoken up there's a woman one in
the posse
is the woman scored I guarantee she's
the least offended person out of all the
people out here that are offended well
she said that that they did have a
conversation but push back on the notion
that I could think the team tweeted out
that he said he regretted and she said
he didn't actually apologize but the two
of them have had a conversation and
we're keeping our eye out for anything
that came out actually might say Michael
Rapaport here on the Rich Eisen show
you're the over the top I think it's I
think it's I think it's so you know what
no wait a minute that means you were
eating Jana yogurt now I'm stopping I'm
gonna fine you were yogurt you have
yogurt your diet Michael is that part of
your is that part of your making sure
that you have a strong bones really that
part of your die I'm sorry I'm sorry
you're acting like you think what do you
think I ate cheeseburgers for breakfast
is that what you're saying
I don't look I didn't I did not mean to
intimate that you did not have a
well-balanced and I do keep yogurt in my
diet it's healthy it keeps things bounce
I know it's good for your stomach and I
do eat Dannon yogurt but you know what
sorry suckers you just lost the customer
I'm offended that you're so freaking
sensitive about a comment that this
Jesus haven't give me a break
Michael Roberts great relax with the
Dannon yogurt you just lost the customer
can I buy about five packs a week see
now now I think this tale is getting a
little taller getting a little taller
you come over to my house okay when
you're not working a football game or
doing your show you come over maybe come
on for some breakfast
me and my wife will make a nice purse
maybe some ice and then we'll absolutely
absolutely everything will be yogurt in
every brunch or breakfast in a row who
knew who knew who do you got for me this
week before before you know before we do
run out of time here
what do you got for me this week fantasy
was am glad that you brought up the fact
that I I her Oakley now it was entirely
because I don't have last week I made
the call on this show Devin Funchess was
the guy I made the big watermelon okay
big bowl comment of Devin Funchess and I
made the big boy play ISAT Amari Cooper
started Devin Funchess and it lost big
time it did and I also I think he
enjoyed the physicality of his routes
right was the question he looks great
I mean he played really well alright so
who do you have for me this week Michael
what he got for me we promise don't
believe the hype Wow Powell had a great
week he did great he performed good
fantasy it ain't gonna happen this much
against the Browns okay okay shut it
down all Raiders this week including
beast mode tonight ball 25 to 30 times
he said the other day this isn't the
eighties he's not at all Campbell
they're not gonna just ride the horse
not Franco Harris not John Rican
that ain't happen oh and do not believe
the hype even though the Titans defense
is the system
do not fall into the hype and think that
Jay Cutler is gonna finally turn things
around is not happening I am sorry
Bronwen re you didn't happen before as
he's gonna tell us who to believe the
hype get that that tweet ready that you
tweeted out last night of Cutler's
comments on running me oh yeah running
me or how he executed his role in the
Wildcat by just standing and not budging
who do you believe the hype on for week
five Michael what are you alright well
you know the first first three weeks I
came on this very show and I said no des
no des no des this is gonna be the
biggest des week of the season verse two
Packard okay James white tonight okay
James white tonight verse Tampa Bay this
is a james white night they have some
deficiencies and some interns at
linebacker James White okay and CY
Hilton verse the Niners that's where you
can win the money if you're in first
start those guys those the guys thank me
later okay or if you see me don't the
thing we just wink at me and you'll know
that I'm the guy that gave you those
answers man white tonight it's gonna get
out okay so because I in my other league
I really could use cuz I got so many
people banged up and on a bye week James
white is available I should pick him up
and play him tonight so what you're
saying pick them up play him and just
you know like I like chocolates I like
wine red wine I like Pinot Grigio pick
them up plan and you know I'm just
saying I like chocolates in wine okay
thank you later
wow I'm gonna do it I'll do it James
white Dez who is the third one Michael I
for the for the believe I yeah we like
to believe the hype he likes James Mike
I hope all right you know you know and
this is a weird thing
if Devante Parker now I know that I
think don't believe the hype on J color
but if somehow or another the planets
are line up okay somehow someway and the
Miami Dolphins live up to even a quarter
of the expectations yeah this will be
the week okay but but but if divided
they could go off if everything lines up
but I am torn because Jay Cutler I call
the smoke
J color but I also called smiling J
color because he tends to smile more
when they're losing that were when
they're winning like he doesn't even
know when to smile him with that smile I
saw about the silent lesson smiling and
I was like no one else was smiling good
kid I didn't know there's control his
facial
what was his soundbite when he was asked
they give this to Michael on the way out
the door yeah yeah about the Wildcat
play he said sit there don't get hit
don't touch anybody
don't move I feel like I executed that
one just collect your ten million
dollars you know what bridge yeah
he's jeopardizing any interest in a
broadcasting future that he that he had
got like I think he won't get a
broadcasting job based on this piece of
this antics and his disposition Wow
Michael Rapaport enjoy being in New York
during the Yankee game brother I'm
jealous
take care we'll chat next week all right
again I'm Michael Rapaport on Twitter
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that please
download our app there's lots of fun
things there other than just more of the
videos you just saw you can call us from
the app you can email us from the app
just download it trust me you'll enjoy